THANK   I,
INVESTIGATIONSND
K UPIN FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP H
ALESO
OFFICIALAREA INTHGOP THATIS
TO TRULY PUT AMERICA
RELATEWHFICIALSMITH, HE TES CN
THIS IUR
BEING WITH
HIS MORNG  TALK AB
UWHY YOU'RETING
>> L THAT, YOU KNOW,WHEND 6, I T
TT
AGAIN, PUT AMERICA FIRST AND BE
ICAN PTY BOMYT I FEEL LIKE BDIS
PROPERTYNDT'S JUSTREEDO WHEN I S
STUDENT.
SO I THINK, YOU KNOWFOR
'SE FOE REPUBLICAN  A C
E  GOING
POLICIES THAT WE'VTRAMP
LICY B, OR ARE WE GOPARTY
THAT CONTINUES TO DOUBLE DOW TH'
GOING TO LISTEE THE O HAVET.
UNTIL W? HAVEN BN INCLIN
>> I G A
ANKS F THIS
N TRUMP
TOFOR THE PRESIDENT ON HIS AIGNN
R TRYING  OURE  OF US SAK
TOHE PARTY, THIS
IS ABOUTAKOR
RIG TO
THE REPUBLICANAR
SO I THINK AS MOREF US MORE OF
WILL FINALLY DO THE  THING
AND WE CAN ACCOMPLE . TOU
AT FROM BELIEVING TOHINKING, ISL
THE ADMINIUT
WHERE OKE WITH THE TRUM THEADMIA
I MEANTH SOMETHING THAT I T GET.
AND I THINHERE I
OF US AND
COGU
AN WHAT HAPPENEDH
SOLE REASON THATWENT AFTER HER O
THEO.
TRAS THEDEMOCRATS WHO INUE TO G,
RE THE
INVEATAT'S
ALLY IMPNT TO NOTE RM COMING  A
NELIT HAS O WITH
THMARCH ANSAYS TWAS,,
WILLFUTEL RMATION.
AS YOU LOOK AT TS YOU'RE
ING THESE ,
TRULD HAVE KEPT
IT T,REPUBLICAN PAR T ABOUT 'VG
AS BECOME LESS ABOUT ARIREUMP FS
THAT'S WHY I THINK HPTIKE A 5-L
, A P DOCUMES. WANT YOU TO LU I
MATCHUDO YOU THINK BIDD ?
>> LOOKNOW, FOR
THEPARTH TACKED, WEAVKE
RON DeSANTIS I OTH
NOT, TIS SOMETHING THAPUO
AN DTHMP. AND THEY WE CAN STILLP
YOU KNOW, M FROM GREAT E OF SOUN
Y, SOMEONE THAT'S P UPTHE F CANS
OULD TAKON JOE BIDR
WHOEVER THE DEMOCRAT
AND 'S REALLY ONO MAKE
AS WEYTH20N, I TRUMP HAVING CLE
FIELD HEREIS
VERSUS BEN
SES RUNNING IN THE
ELN
INDEPENDENT, BUT I CAN TELL YO